carlin the idea for safety not
guaranteed came from a classified ad
asking for a time travel buddy which
went viral and became an internet meme
now I know the guy who wrote that
original ad has a little cameo in the
movie why don't you tell me how you
found him and how he compares to mark
Duplass as eccentric inventor character
in the film they're not that similar as
human beings there's one thing that's
consistent in that they both bring their
own weapons or wherever they go that's
true story but you know he just wants to
be prepared and he he is in the film
there's a moment when Aubrey Plaza's
character is staking out the post office
waiting for mark Duplass to show up and
the first guy that comes to the p.o box
a gray beard and some glasses and that's
the original water the film's got a very
down-to-earth feel as well and I know
you sent mark Duplass off with a small
digital camera to shoot some separate
footage which we used in the film tell
me a bit about that yet so that was it
was actually supposed to be for the for
the EPK and it was never going to be
used in the movie and he had a day off
he was only with us for the first two
weeks of the four weeks shoot and so he
was shooting pretty consistently but
there was one day where we had to get
something and so I sent him and one of
our producers and a camera guy just to
Kenneth's house which which really looks
exactly the way it does in the movie we
found this old house that it had moss
like grown all over it I just said look
we just need a day of you just being
Kenneth just be this guy and I knew you
know Mark has a set of skills where you
can just give him that very simple
direction and it'll bring you back a
wealth of material so he went set up
this whole you know obstacle course and
he gave interviews in various places and
I we we've been cutting the film for a
while and then I was just at my house
and I was looking I came upon all this
footage and I cut together this little
sequence that I felt you know could work
if we just suggested that Aubrey was
shooting him and it ended up becoming
like really this crucial tonal turning
point in the movie and we put it right
in the middle and its really where it
goes from you know being kind of a
madcap comedy to something a little bit
more emotionally resonant and then we
use it again at the very end is the last
thing you see is is is that and you know
I feel like
you have if I did anything right on this
movie it was knowing that I had really
talented writers in these actors that
we're working for us and I gave them all
a lot of space in a lot of room to to
bring their own material to the
characters and it wasn't just with Mark
it really is with everybody you
mentioned the house said it was very
much like it appears in the film and i
believe it was also a little bit creepy
in real life too why didn't you give us
a bit of insight into why that was yeah
where did you read all this stuff this
is you've got some deep background that
house we we weren't going to use it
initially we had another location and we
I kept driving by that house on the way
to this other location that we were
shooting and I kept seeing it and
feeling like that bats cats house we got
to go there so we we just walked up and
knocked on the door and it turned out
that the guy who owned this property had
grown up here and he lived elsewhere on
this on the property and this was his
mother's homes childhood home and he had
pretty much left it untouched since his
mother died and the upstairs weren't
even allowed to go upstairs and we heard
that everything was like pristine up
there and so there was like locks on the
door and I and it really like the earth
had kind of grown up around it so
there's just like ferns growing off the
the roof and and it looks like one of
these things that you know we pick me
and spend a hundred thousand dollars
trying to make a house look like this
and we spend zero dollars and just like
that truck which was in kind of the same
area of Washington we that was in the
location that we were shooting the
ending at and we just stumbled on this
truck that looks exactly the way it does
in the movie and again you know $50,000
they to make something look that old and
weathered and as one of the great things
about shooting in in Washington State I
feel like you know in the 90s when
everything in America got new again and
they built all these malls and they
fixed up everything like Washington just
stayed looking like the 80s and they
kept all the old neon signs and it has
this character to it that much of
America has has lost and I really wanted
to keep that character another thing has
a loss of character in the film is that
very distinctive yellow dancin car that
mark drives and that gave you a few
headaches during filming didn't it it
did you know we bought that Datsun for
eight hundred dollars off of Craigslist
and when you do that you're going to
you're definitely going to have some
malfunctions and one of them was that it
had a it had a screwdriver starter and
so we put a push-button starter in there
we had guys that were trying to work on
this thing and make it function and
unfortunately when we were going to
shoot the big car chase see the
slow-motion car chase sequence the car
wouldn't start and we had no choice
because you know we're a low-budget film
we weren't going to get to come back to
that location we just had to push it and
make it seem as if it were moving so and
you can that we have footage of it
actually where you see the interior this
thing it looks like he's driving this
car and then the outside you've got this
big bar and like eight guys pushing this
thing as quickly as possible but that
was actually like that invigorated me
that day I think was my favorite day of
shooting because it was just this moment
where we just no one could figure out
how we were possibly going to make it
work and I had to go into the corner and
and I drew it was like I was a kid with
like the bottle caps like then the car
is going to move here and then okay
you're you know you're the Twinkie
you're going to go over here and it was
just so fun i love it after this gem of
a movie you've made with safety not
guaranteed you going on to something
with a little bit of a bigger budget
you're moving on to Disney's a flight of
the navigator now it's not going to be a
straight remake or a sequel or something
similar to what happened with tron tron
legacy right well it's not it's not my
next film it's something that's going to
take a while to build and my next film
is called intelligent life and it's it's
another ND it's it's bigger in scope and
definitely in budget than this last one
but I don't think it's possible to make
for less but that one and then we have
another original that were that we wrote
for Disney as well that we're excited
about but navigator is one of those
things that you know we got to get it
right and and we're going to we're going
to probably go through many different
iterations of how to tackle that and
it's something that it's interesting
dynamics I care about it very much it's
something that I grew up really loving
Derek doesn't have the same connection
to it and I think that's actually part
of what makes the dynamic work between
us because I'm gonna have to convince
him like this is why you care about this
right now and and there's another
project that he loves that will probably
be the same way where it's you know it's
like dwarves and wizards and stuff and
stuff I don't really care
about and I'm gonna have to be like why
do I care about this wizard right now
explain this to me but you need that and
you know as far as how we're going to do
it you know I know how I know we know
what our themes are and we know what our
characters are and ultimately I I feel
like you know it just has to be
something that that really captures that
same fear that that first one did of
what would happen if you know if your
family suddenly you know if you show up
in your in your parents are old and the
world has moved on without you and I
think especially at that moment in life
you know to be a 12 year old kid and
you're just you're just kind of coming
to the point where everyone's changing
around you and especially if you're on
the younger side of that and you've got
all these kids who look 14 and you still
look 11 there's sort of a feeling that
like you know the world is moving
quicker than you are and I think there's
a lot of a lot of really resonant themes
that are in that movie that I think we
can pull out and as far as how we're
going to do it you know where it'll be a
while before we can say for sure and of
course there's been so much speculation
which you've recently quashed about your
involvement with the next Star Wars
movie episode 7 but you have described
yourself in the past as a Star Wars kid
so now that some of your next movies are
with Disney who recently bought
Lucasfilm how psyched would you be to be
able to make a future star wars movie
would you throw your hat in the ring for
another star wars movie if the
opportunity arose oh absolutely i mean i
think that you know for me dad I don't
think I'm alone in that I think there's
a lot of people who grew up when I grew
up that you know when given the
opportunity to go into that universe
they would they would absolutely take it
and you know what I what I think is
interesting about this whole this whole
thing and in talking to friends of mine
who when they heard this was going to
happen like it was almost like a
religious they like it's really
interesting to see like how much people
care about this and I think for for
people who you know we're kids at that
time who were like six and seven it so
informed our worldview in this and I
think that a lot of us are still trying
to get our heads around you know the
idea that we get to go back there and so
that way you know I look at it you know
only as a as a fan and it's been I know
they're going to do an incredible job
and it sits by I think Michael Arndt is
an unbelievably brilliant choice as
I feel like you're eighty-five percent
of the way there with him it's exciting
so you definitely put your hand up for
episode eight or nine if that happened I
look I think that if what they're what
they're going to do what it seems like
they're doing is they're gonna really
delve deep into that universe and it's
very exciting I I personally feel that
it's important that I take some steps
like I don't necessarily want to go from
a 750 thousand dollar movie to a
billion-dollar franchise I feel like you
know when when you grow up wanting to be
a filmmaker really your reward is is
that you get to make films that you care
about and that our original that are
yours and I feel like it's a gift right
now that I can tell original stories and
I'm not really sure if I want to
exchange that gift yet for something
that I definitely would love in the
future but I'm it's it's pretty exciting
that I get to go and make another movie
at all I mean whenever anyone asked me
like what my dream project is it's
whatever the next movie I get to make is
that's that's the dream just actually
doing it and it's a fun yourself where
would you like to see the series go what
do you like to see happen next oh man I
all I am as a fan when it when it comes
to that I you know I think that all of
those movies are speaking solely as a
fan I have no knowledge of anything all
of those movies are based on on a
fundamental iconic dynamic and you know
the the original films were about it was
oedipal it was father and son and and
the the prequel trilogy was was about
master and apprentice and so I'm really
curious to know like what is the dynamic
that's going to be the anchor of these
new movies but I think that's what's so
amazing about what George Lucas created
is it's just something that that reaches
way back to the very beginning of
storytelling and I know that all of them
are very conscious of that and finally
there's a great line and safety not
guaranteed where mark tells his
potential time travel buddy played by
Aubrey Plaza that she's not to do
anything in the past that might change
things in the future like tell people to
leave their star wars figures in the
boxes so they'll be worth more and what
would you find difficult to resist
changing if you could time travel how
you know I probably you know just for my
fear of like unraveling
entire universe i would probably stick
to really personal things but not like I
wouldn't have worn that two that eighth
grade dance I mean like I'll let that
stuff go but you know just probably more
you know I might have been nicer to my
dad on that day or you know just ways
that ideally like you know if you can go
back and start you know you get to play
Monday Morning Quarterback on your life
with a time machine and you can just go
back to little moments and just do some
tweaks and sort of make yourself a
better person and in retrospect which we
probably like that's that's a privilege
we probably shouldn't have because you
know then we would have no self control
at all I'll just go back and tweak this
but I'm gonna do it first exactly like
you any live ones except you only live
twice yeah I got the time machine will
be fine
you